I'd like to start today with Law and Order or law
and auto depending on your preference I know that
it feels like just yesterday that the failed
former president Donald Trump went from being a
once indicted president to a twice indicted former
president but we are now potentially inching
up imminently on Donald Trump's third arrested
indictment and potentially even fourth arrest and
indictment there is a very interesting report from
NBC News five or six Secret Service agents have
testified before the January 6 grand jury sources
say it is not known what the agent's proximity to
Trump was on January 6th or what information they
may have provided through the grand jury it's
important to remember that and it's hard to keep
track of I admit if you're busy working listen I
work in doing this and it's hard to keep track of
all of the investigations and potential arrests
that are forthcoming involving the failed former
president um if you have like a real job I can
only imagine that it is a mess of confusion what
is going on Donald Trump has been arrested and
indicted at the state level in New York Donald
Trump has been arrested and indicted federally
related to the classified documents Fiasco there
is a concurrent federal investigation into Donald
Trump's role related to the January 6th riots so
while that is going on we also have to remember
what's going on in Georgia with Bonnie Willis so
let's go through the possible forthcoming arrests
I don't really know which one we would call
the third or the fourth what I mean by that
is we don't exactly know which is likely to happen
first or next but the next federal arrest would be
related to the house committee investigation into
the January 6 Trump riots those investigations
led to criminal referrals to the justice
department federal charges remember and they
relate to allegations belief the suggestion that
Donald Trump attempted to incite an Insurrection
participated in a conspiracy to defraud the United
States obstructed official proceedings conspiracy
to make false statements Etc all of that has been
referred to the justice department for potential
Federal prosecution that's what this is all about
the Secret Service agents that testified the
um subject matter presumably about which they were
asked and testified all relates to a concurrent
special counsel investigation by Jack Smith Jack
Smith is the same special prosecutor involved in
Trump's existing Federal indictment this may be
a second Federal indictment spokeswoman for the
secret service has so far declined to comment
the content of the subpoenas and appearances
is not known Secret Service agents who were
close to Trump on January 6th may be able to
confirm deny or provide more details on that
story first told by Cassidy Hutchinson you of
course remember her explosive testimony under
oath by the way under oath we then get to the
potential fourth arrest the fourth arrest would
come out of Fulton County Georgia this is the
arrest the investigation rather being handled
by the district attorney fonnie Willis and this
relates to Trump's attempt to overturn the results
in Georgia remember that Joe Biden won Georgia in
the sense that he received more votes than Donald
Trump I know that now and you know for all of the
attacks from the ride about postmodern leftists
were words no longer have meaning what we mean by
Trump lost and Biden won is that Biden received
more votes in concurrence with the will of the
voters of Georgia it's not super complicated
he won in this sense that he got more votes
than Trump that's where Trump's famous phone call
where he said I need 11 000 votes give me a break
that entire Fiasco is the subject matter of the
Georgia investigation from which a fourth arrest
could come a special grand jury heard evidence
in that case for roughly seven months and um
there were a dozen or so indictments recommended
it was hinted at by that zany and kooky jury 4
person that Trump may be among those recommended
indictments we will uh see probably uh during that
session of the grand jury the the grand jury
term from July 11th to September 1st that is
the time range during which we would expect that
arrest so as we continue to see that nobody else
in the 2024 Republican primary seems to be able
to make any progress Chris Christie as as we
said yesterday tongue-in-cheek Chris Christie's
polling has surged 150 percent from one percent
to 2.5 percent but DeSantis Ron de sanctimonious
he's flat um Nikki Haley four percent you know
everybody's flat and Trump is essentially flat as
well nobody seems to be able to make any progress
against Trump despite now two arrests would a
third arrest damage Trump would a fourth arrest
damage Trump increasingly my guess is that
the answer is no we may find out about that
soon let's now talk about an explosive development
remember Law and Order folks Law and Order you've
got to have law you've got to have order explosive
development in Trump's existing Federal indictment
sometimes it can be tough to maintain an emotional
connection with your significant other you might
work in different places at different times there
might be a kid in the way it can be hard to find
time for date nights especially because kids
demand so much attention which is why I love
our sponsor paired which is the app for couples
the app will prompt you with a daily question or
a game or a guided conversation all designed by
Leading psychologists and the point is to just
have a deeper connection with your partner boost
intimacy build a deeper knowledge of one another
my girlfriend and I will use the prompts on paired
throughout the day to stay connected for instance
we answered a prompt about what we remember most
from the early days of the relationship it really
helps us learn new things and there can be
funny moments as well an independent study
found that couples using paired saw 36 percent
increase in the quality of their relationship
and giving a paired subscription as a gift is
also a really great idea you can try it free
for seven days and get 25 off a subscription go
to pair.com Pacman the link is in the description